what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we got ourselves a
Spider-Man dose trailer so excited for
this game Andrew and I reviewed the
mouse and Ross one here on this channel
we still often talk about on our own
time the first Spider-Man game Sandra
you excited hey everyone yes I am uh I
freaking love that PS4 game and it's so
good in the Miles Morales one you can
say it is an extended DLC whatever but I
enjoyed the heck out of that game it was
a good in-betweener and cannot wait for
this I'm so excited between Tony Tony
Todd voicing Venom and everything else I
can't wait nice nice Andrew showed he
knows information and that's what you
guys like about him be sure to whip that
like button also want to say a special
thank you to everyone who bought a real
rejects exclusive space babies of the
Galaxy t-shirt it is almost our number
one selling shirt at shopzeroedition.com
we got a whole bunch of stuff over there
whole bunch of great designs and uh it's
one of the best places to support the
channel one of the best ways to support
your fashion sense when you're out
public so go ahead and buy one Link in
the description box let's watch this
trick
what we got damn
feeling all Predator Style
is that Craven
yes
yes doesn't have the
fur the line yeah
yeah that's craving I don't know
he's hunting Sergey it fate you will not
share yeah there we go
wow
faster
I've been in your Shadow for hours but
since nothing
pathetic and sweet
he's really menacing
cool
[Music]
go Aaron Taylor Johnson I was gonna say
it looks just like Aaron Taylor Johnson
I asked for an equal
oh you'll find him in New York City is
what you find
sir
perhaps
a new hunting ground
fairly comic accurate yeah yeah oh the
prowler yes Ray
Spidermans
lizard nice doctor what a great tease
yeah
the Rogue Gallery yeah
great hunts big games
well Sony's not giving us Cravings last
hunt but at least the video game is
love the music
started in Queens causing it now
cover the door who are they the Beast
could be anywhere
do they work for Craven
[Applause]
oh
damn
oh my God
holy [__] I can't believe we got this
yes I can't believe we got this
Spider-Man three move out of the way
wow
crazy you want to hunt I'll give him one
he'll never forget
um
oh thank you I got just chills
everywhere right now
oh
amazing amazing hi that Spider-Man 3
video game was amazing wow triangular
position
all teams converge lizards across the
river yeah oh sweet he said Connor's oh
you can hop back and forth to see him
playing yeah
blizzard I'm on it sounds like Craven's
checking off his we don't have much time
move
uh guess we'll chat later huh
that's so pulsating
oh got in the gliding abilities yeah I
was just loose at the fish market this
looks great holy [__]
and really tough what have they done
I'll boot up and see you there
I love this
I love it so much
how amazing was that symbiote moment
yeah
he's done for it
[Music]
sure
wow
spread out
stealth mode
that's great that's really convenient
look at those fish it's been feeding
wow
that's really cool you get a place both
of them yeah
[Music]
how's the hunt going whoa
return the dead fish not well
oh shoot oh
garage my lead to him he's even cooler
in this game than he was on his own
and he's pretty damn cool in that too
yeah I know I loved him of that
Connor's tore through this place
Trove lizard I just can't wait this game
feels so much more monstrous doesn't it
yeah
can feel a little more of a horror
element to this game amen
like the guts of the fish and stuff yeah
yeah yeah makes sense he's a lizard we
want fish
oh
I seriously can't wait to play this game
yeah
I'm just gonna be locked in for hours on
this
how'd you find me follow the fish
drones picking up lizards Trail
I can catch him off guard so it's an
assist it's not a vulture yeah yeah like
a drone
unless there's something I'm forgetting
about from the previous game is he
shedding
yep doesn't that mean he's getting
bigger
too
amen
new threats the building's swarming with
Hunters that looks so good
he's tracking them hey Mr Parker
Mr Spider-Man what I mean
but the date is incomplete
okay I think I got a lock is that okay I
figured that was Yankee yeah that's
about to say that me neither
I don't even have a stomach so
go
wow
go go go
oh you gotta go through the actual water
and harbor and all that
oh my god wow Harry's so good oh yeah
yes you take the Drone and the jet skis
[Music]
it's like no Spider-Man meets Uncharted
keep it tight man watch out for those
drones don't worry they think I'm a
friendly
man they're really off their game here
wow oh my God
oh my God it's like Godzilla I know
exactly so water title flat but
Spiderman is fighting on right now
[Music]
so massive right I feel like the metal
murder bird yeah
I warned you about going after Cutters
now this is on you I love the anger in
his voice yeah
Yuri lowenthal
um
done here
it's a physical take it down together
Andrew
time to go boom boys no no Spider-Man is
good
defenses whoa
whoa Spiderman hang on
I like how he still calls him Spider-Man
yeah yeah you know you never know who's
maybe listening into but they just call
each other like there's no it's not
Spider-Man one or Spider-Man 2
Spider-Man
that is terrifying wow yes I love when
he does that
it's like a mini Kaiju movie
I know I know there it is
oh hump that thing Craven
oh wow I do not want to be Liverpool
surfing Spiderman I love that they
implemented this level
oh
it's comparable to fighting Rhino but a
million times scarier yeah
can't get close enough but I can and one
of them remember bro that's it
now the youth on three they are so much
destruction
I love that detail then by working
together yeah
incredible
you really are The Amazing Spider-Man
just throws him
oh yeah you're concerned for as well
away from us
Good Pete
I saved the tracker
let's go man before he gets too far no
it's mine
that suit ah it's got big teeth
so do I yeah
um he's not normally like that yeah I
was like what the hell is he talking
about with his teeth
he's never like that
yeah
that's really cool we're getting the
actual symbi is that been 12 minutes
that went by so fast
I want 12 more
2023 pre-order now
I eventually have to implement streaming
at least one game on this channel
I wonder if it'll be this one uh yeah
fun that was absolutely
amazingly incredible when when they
announced that Venom would be in this I
mean going off of the post-credits scene
was it a post credit
it was the end that it seemed like it
would be Eddie not Eddie Brock um
freaking Harry Osborne uh becoming Venom
and so I didn't even think they would
actually do the traditional path where
Peter Parker is the one who gets uh you
know joined with the symbiote suit at
first and he goes through that whole
dark Journey uh but I love that we
actually get to experience that so that
way we're not just versing Venom in this
game we actually get to experience what
it's like to be Venom in this game as
well and yeah everything about it I
think you know we said plenty during the
actual reaction itself normally we save
a lot of that before the top person
during the reaction yeah but yeah the it
just felt incredibly monstrous
throughout like that was actually a
scare there's parts of here where you
can liken it like you know uh Rhino to
lizard and yet this one they really
Amplified just like everything just
feels much more you know Amplified it's
my it's maximum I love it I love this I
love this whole trailer it's so good and
freaking craving it starts off with
crazy like damn that shit's gonna be
crazy and then so you're like never mind
this is great wait no never mind this is
the part that's crazy and then by the
time they come back to craving you're
like you're nothing crazy compared to
all this yeah and I mean Craven looks
you look really menacing and scary and
threatening at the beginning I'm like
how's he supposed to go up against that
lizard but I mean obviously though it'll
make sense when we play the game but uh
there's so many different things to
unpack here this was outstanding uh just
I love one thing that we touched upon
during the reaction was just the horror
element it just it really feels scary
and I love the example you put of you
know it's like facing Rhino just a
little more menacing a little more uh
with like a Godzilla effect if you will
in terms of the lizard but uh I like two
how they're really nailing the tone in
terms of Peter with you know the with
the the symbiote suit I just think it's
much better than him just dancing on the
street uh sorry Sam Remy um
I think the thing too one of the things
I'm more interested in this game from a
story perspective is Miles Morales and
Peter Parker because they have a very
really interesting relationship in my
opinion and I love the way they they
interact with each other they both have
tragic pasts and it's like his little
they're like you know Little Brother Big
Brother and seeing your big brother like
fall so deep and like come you know
getting infected with the darkness if
you will and then like losing yourself I
just I think that's going to create such
an interesting dichotomy obviously the
gameplay the action all looks freaking
amazing but what we loved from the PS4
game that we got and even the Miles
Morales when I know this short the story
was very short in that game we got
really interesting characters we got
great story lines and again this was
just gameplay but the little hints of
detail that we get the the uh
the um the interactions between miles
and Peter you can tell there's going to
be some intense I don't know rivalry is
the right word but there's going to be
issues that arise from him like saying
he's not ever like that and I'm just
like little things like that make me
just so giddy and excited obviously the
game plan action like oh my God I'm
gonna be doing that for hours but I mean
the storyline and the character
interactions just intrigued me the most
actually yeah I mean I think you're
hitting the nail on the head there
because when it comes to miles I imagine
that he will be the force of light that
can help pull Peter out of the darkness
as opposed to Peter you know just going
to a church going to a bad lineup but uh
I feel like it'll be miles who'll be the
one to pull him out of the darkness but
I love the juxtaposition that they draw
here with Peter and the villains that he
has here like bringing these villains to
life who feel like there's something
there's there is a quality of them that
just feels exceptionally darker than the
villains from the last game like there's
something here that does feel a little
bit more like from hell and a little
weird odd way right and so he for him
feeling like he has to succumb to the
darkness in order to defeat the villains
is really cool to me so I imagine that
he'll have to come around to a point
where he does feel like he has to you
know like find a way to defeat evil with
light being you know Spider-Man friendly
neighborhood Spider-Man at the same time
I am hoping that while I love the choice
to let you play as Peter with a symbiote
attached to him or bonded with him I
still hope that we get plenty of time
where they are reversing you know Venom
himself and that becomes like an actual
storyline and a real thing that you get
to explore as opposed to like Spider-Man
three yeah where it's like it just gets
tacked on and you don't get enough time
to live with it yeah I really hope that
you get a long time post this like I
hope this game is much longer that way
you can really see what it's like to
deal with both you know I think also I
mean I want to give credit to Yuri
lowenthal as Peter Parker I know again
this is just a small little snippet but
obviously he was beyond phenomenal in
the first game uh but like the little
Snippets we get here of just his anger
his coldness just throwing like little
details of throwing the guy after he
saves him because he's pissed he just
like because he I had to save you you
let lizard or you know my
responsibilities led the lizard it's
getting away just really sticking the
landing for me when it comes to just uh
that anger and the coldness of wearing
that symbiote suit so I I have no
worries that they're gonna you know
Excel when it comes to him wearing that
thing I don't know if you played the
Spider-Man 3 video game I believe it was
on Xbox 360 and PS3 but that game in my
opinion was a lot of fun you got to play
with the symbiote suit
um I thought that was one of the better
versions of doing of getting to play
with the symbiat suit
no comparison this is uh just on another
Stratosphere another level but I mean
yeah just everything we got to see and
this was just amazing from the music to
the horror elements the character
interactions there's just so much to
look forward to when it comes to this
that was perfect man that was perfect
guys what did you think about this
trailer leave your thoughts down below
please make sure to follow andrewake or
7-Eleven on his socials uh you can
subscribe leave a like and hey let us
know in the comments if you if we were
to do like a let's play here before this
would you guys actually tune in and
watch that [__] we want to know and
thank you again everyone about yourself
space babies at the galaxy shirt got a
bunch of other tea over there as well
peace out reject Nation
that is uh that that seems uh like I'm
implying okay
[Music]